you guys did it to us again with the
season 8 premiere yet another
cliffhanger
lucas has to see again elizabeth hanging
out with nathan
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nathan i'm so sorry i'm not feeling very
well
would you mind terribly walking us home
[Music]
ah no of course chris i want to ask you
what is going through lucas's head in
that moment
i think his dreams are being slowly
crushed
um it's just an it's just another you
know step towards or in the in the wrong
direction for him so
i think on the other hand he does kind
of leave to
leave ho valley for a while to gain some
perspective on
on the situation and when he comes back
he comes back because he realizes he
just
he wants to be with elizabeth but he
also wants her to be happy and that's
the most important thing
kevin can you kind of share what nathan
is feeling i think any interaction with
uh
nathan and lucas is always uncomfortable
i think for
this point in the nathan elizabeth
journey i think things might
we might actually get to see a date with
the two of them so yeah he's hopeful
when they had to about face and walk
elizabeth and baby jack home
how did he feel have you ever been
rejected
in the moment the moment you're about to
sit down for dinner
like an arrow just you know we have to
of course respect where elizabeth's
heart is at and
respect what she wants to do in the
moment erin can you kind of talk to me
about
why elizabeth made that decision to
ultimately
pump the brakes on going to dinner
it's just an impossible situation
because
both nathan and lucas are such
incredible men
and you know they've created
these amazing characters that we've all
grown to
love and i think like no matter what
elizabeth is just in quite the pickle
but in that moment specifically i think
it's just too much it's one of these
things where like you know maybe if they
hadn't run into
lucas and his mother on the way
it would have been easier to just keep
walking into that cafe
but i think it just felt like it just
didn't
feel kind i guess and i think in that
moment elizabeth realized she still had
a lot to think about and
and she was just she's just trying to
follow her heart
kevin we have joked and talked many
times about how
we'd really like to see nathan step his
game up nathan is bad at talking to
girls
i need to know how and i have to tell
you he really did it in the
season eight premiere episode things
couldn't be better
unless of course you uh you agreed to
have dinner with me this evening what
can you tell me about
this confidence are we gonna see more of
it in season eight and and how does it
make you feel
yeah i think 100 we're going to see more
of it i think the way it's
um finished season seven with kind of
the near-death experience
um just kind of shook some things into
perspective for nathan
of what he wants and and what it takes
to get it um
however this is really just kind of the
tip of the iceberg of what
nathan has been kind of holding on to um
i find it interesting a lot of people
kind of talk they're always like oh you
know like nathan's so
shy and you know you kind of he's
they're very quick to be like he's he's
got all these attributes but very few
people are like why is he like this
and i think we get to see that and this
is
a really good answer actually um as as
this kind of moves on
and so he starts off much more confident
um at the beginning of season eight
because i think of kind of the
near-death experience of what happened
at the end of season seven but things
start to unravel a little bit
and some truths come up to the surface a
little bit and we get to see just
why he has been so kind of you know at
arm's length
especially with elizabeth he's only
tongue-tied around elizabeth so we kind
of figure out
what's going on there chris i want to
ask you about a moment
in the season 8 premiere that's a lot of
money
whatever this is about it must be
serious for you to ask me for help
it was a very gracious act of kindness
to see lucas lend nathan the money
without question and without hesitation
are we gonna be seeing nathan and
lucas's friendship
continue to grow and blossom hopefully
we get picked up for season nine so that
we
could i would say that
we're kind of setting the stage of
coming from a place of mutual respect
towards one another where a friendship
could be down the line kevin what did
that mean to nathan
to be able to turn to an unlikely
friend like lucas and to have such a you
know generous act of kindness
oh for for the chump change he pulled
out of his pocket he's like here i got
uh
nothing for lucas
no of course you know nathan had to
swallow his pride
but that you know it says something
about luca's character you know that he
helps he helped out nathan
okay i want i want all three of your
opinions at the end of
episode one who do you think has the
competitive edge with elizabeth's heart
i don't know i mean those last three
seconds are really kind of
the interception that was nathan's
football game
yeah you really kind of stole it in the
last few seconds that episode
i think it depends what the perspective
is so from an audience perspective maybe
it looks like lucas might have an upper
hand
um as elizabeth has decided to not go
through with the
with the dinner date but from luke this
is perspective he's
definitely thinks that nathan is has got
it i would really just love for the
audience to try to
to track it on their own and figure out
where they think elizabeth is with all
of this
time goes by so slowly
standing next to me
paul green playing some music of course
carson was serenading
faith out by the water it was very
romantic was that paul's idea
john has been very open to collaboration
and our thoughts and
and so it may have been something that
john and paul talked about
you know the fans have been burning
with desire to get this duet between
aaron
and kevin and here we go right
i now like to know the status of our
duet
and also can we expect any music
from you throughout season eight as far
as
the mcgary cracow duet
i think it would have been a lot easier
if we if we had done it while we were in
the same city
but i would love for it to happen it
will happen
we have a song we were gonna do yes we
have a song we have actually rehearsed
the song a little bit
we maybe we just need to download one of
those karaoke apps where it's like split
screen
and do it that way i don't know we'll
figure something out i can't split
myself into though i'm conducting it
i need
just so we give the fans a little
something can you share the song or can
you share the artist
it's a song that feels
connected to one calls the heart and
some of the sentiments that were shared
uh on our show will we see nathan
playing any music
will we see elizabeth doing anything in
this season of one calls the heart
i do sing this season actually i sing to
elizabeth's favorite person we have a
sweet little musical moment together
my gosh i cannot wait to see it and
we're going to hold out hope for
the mcnally led conducted
krakow mcnerry duet of the of the 21st
century
[Music]
perfect